downtown Seoul turned into a showcase
for military might every branch of the
South Korean military is represented
here
I feel reassured from not having a
military parade for so many years to
seeing one now I feel a deep sense of
Pride
I feel a little bit overwhelmed it's
really cool to look at there's a sense
of youthful energy and it's quite moving
it's a complex emotion
South Korea used to hold a military
parade every five years on its Armed
Forces Day
but in 2018 then president Moon jae-in
opted for something more colorful as
part of efforts to improve relations
with North Korea
but the leader now president Yun sub Yol
is known for his more Hardline stance
towards the North
if North Korea uses nuclear weapons its
regime will be brought to an end by an
overwhelming response from the South
Korea U.S Alliance For the First Time
troops from the U.S army are taking part
in the parade
some analysts say they're not surprised
president Yoon has opted for military
Showmanship to Mark Armed Forces Day
he's emphasized strengthening defense
capabilities as a form of deterrence
against the increase in military threats
from North Korea but peace activists say
the parade is meaningless and
counterproductive
it looks childish it comes across as we
are so powerful Don't Mess With Us North
Korea is doing the exact same thing do
we really need to waste energy bragging
about our strength claiming this brings
real peace makes no sense tensions on
the Korean Peninsula are at their
highest in recent years with Pyongyang
conducting a record number of weapons
tests last year there are also concerns
about North Korea's increasing closeness
to Russia that may extend to military
cooperation that could boost pyongyang's
nuclear weapons program
those concerns have prompted the union
Administration to renew diplomatic
efforts to de-escalate tensions on the
Korean Peninsula Senior diplomats from
China Japan and South Korea met in Seoul
on Tuesday to revive a summit between
the three countries leaders that had
been suspended since 2019.
a date has not been confirmed but
they've agreed to hold that Summit as
soon as they can
Florence Louis Al Jazeera Seoul
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera